we often train our phd students in our
own image that is for a life in academia
but the truth is that
just like
there's a paucity of core jobs for
bachelor students there is a paucity of
academic jobs for all phd students it's
the truth
all across the globe
may be less so in india compared to the
us but india is fast catching up to that
grim picture where there is a huge
difference between the number of phd
graduates every year and the number of
academic jobs like good academic jobs in
respectable institutes
that are available
so is it not perhaps time for us to
maybe tune our training and supervision
of phd students in such a way that they
can be better prepared for a life in
industry
yes i i strongly believe so in fact
when i ask my students as well here that
okay what do you want to do after this
when the first enter they all want to do
uh you know they're always
they want to pursue a career in academia
i'll do a phd
right i want to do
so that's what they come with but slowly
i think it's our duty also to expose
them
to industrial research
to people
in the in industrial r d so that they
get a feel of that okay not all of us
probably will
it is not possible for someone to work
on an industrial r d project because
sometimes those come with their own
with their own constraints you may not
be allowed to publish etc so your main
phd problem can be something but if
there are some side problems that you
can give to the student to work on
additionally
trust me that is going to help a lot
okay and
then about the big picture i have seen
students
my seniors uh so
who have done a very academic kind of
phd but did end up going to uh to
industry
so exactly so
that is the question of which skills are
transferable and how the students is
able to apply himself in those uh kind
of skills
so i'll tell you a story rather
interesting one
my my first interview 20 years back
um
i went in and then there was this senior
person who later on became a very close
friend and one of and mentor
uh he's also very accomplished
researcher
his name is ravi prashar
okay yes i think he has given you a
testimony on your linkedin profile i
think correct
so i sat down with ravi
so first thing is he said that
i'm gonna i'm gonna conduct a technical
interview okay and then in the half an
hour one question after the other okay
he would write something on his notebook
and say what is this what is this what
is this
and most of the times i was i didn't
know what i was what i was answering
most of the most of the questions i
couldn't answer even if some of the
answers which i thought i gave correctly
he had no expression on his face he said
okay let's move on let's move on to the
next one
which is said to questions which i could
not answer which is which he said
which was reaction to questions which i
could answer so i had no idea how i did
and my own impression was i did
extremely poorly okay i could hardly
answer anything
and after that you know interviews are
little different over there
and in industry overall is it was a i
was a fresh phd student i had an
interview starting at 8 am which ended
at 5 pm
starting with some interactions with the
hiring manager followed by a seminar
and then followed by a bunch of
one-on-one interviews
across across the board and because i
was it was a recession time even people
at the level of vp came down to
interview me
okay so after ravi's interview
i just kept it i i took it very lightly
because i thought that i
mean this is a job i'm not going to get
i'm majorly goofed up then i got the job
and i asked him that
was how could you hire me after that
performance
he said no and in fact i came to know
that he was the person who was actually
championing me there was another
candidate who many people thought was
better than me
but
ravi really fought for me and got me the
job okay
by the way that other person was
apparently from stanford was first from
stanford university okay
so you can see that how much we have to
fight to get somebody uh
to
get somebody ahead of a stanford
graduate phd graduate
so anyway um i asked him later that how
could you hire me he said i could hardly
answer he said i was not looking for
answers
i was looking for
your thought process
i was i was looking at how you are
attacking these problems some of the
some of the questions i don't expect
anybody to know the answers or many very
few people to know the answers
but what i was trying to say is whether
i was trying to examine your train of
thoughts
and your way of attacking a problem
okay
so
why i took this personal example is i
want to
again i again repeat that phd is an
education it's not about solving working
on a particular problem and publish
writing a thesis
it's this quality that you have to pick
up as to how to
attack a problem with an unknown
solution in a systematic manner breaking
it up and going to a certain level so
ravi was actually examining to what
level i could go and from there he would
move on to the next question
okay and he tried that on a variety of
problems to see that whether i am able
to
show this because some questions may be
in my domain and i may know some
questions
i may not know so he was he was trying
all that this is what he told me later
probably he was also testing you on your
flexibility to context switch
absolutely and and how far what what the
scene industry is the term can you think
on your feet yes okay and this is one i
i throw something because and and you
have to you have to think and come up
either with a decision or or a method
and can you do that you have you
developed that capability
so that is something and also i i'll
tell you all uh that you know i have
seen
especially in india
several phd students stellar cv in terms
of publications or even background
but uh you know when it came to
questions just outside his immediate
problem
they faltered
okay that that that ex we expected
somebody with with a sound fundamental
understanding to answer
you most people faltered there
okay so that cannot happen
when you are going to an industry you
are not going to work on what you want
on your phd problem in your postdoc
years postdoc if somebody's looking for
a postdoc he would that would be for a
certain project and
that professor would be looking for
someone who has worked in a similar
field so that that person can come and
start giving output right away
industry is going to put you on on his
on its own problem
okay so you should develop this
capability
to work on problems with unknown
solutions
okay that's industrial r d
uh very recently one of my phd students
is going to defend next friday
he
he is right now working mahindra
electric mobility
okay mahindra electric mobility
particularly working on battery
technologies central motors and all
you know what was his phd on his phd was
a numerical modeling of full boiling
heat transfer using something called
lattice worksman method
absolutely no relation to what he's
doing in his job today
why did mahindra hire him
okay they tested him there when he went
through three four rounds of interviews
and then they hired him and i think that
goes wrong here in india right three
four rounds of interview for psja
students yeah absolutely in industry
that's the norm
yeah because they were testing his his
skills the skills that he has which is
the transferable skills does he have an
analytical mind
can he attack an unknown problem
and if that is there a person can be
successful anywhere and does he have the
basic fundamental knowledge in that area
which is in our case primarily in fluid
mechanics heat transfer thermodynamics
etcetera and so that's what his work and
solid mechanics all right
yeah and after that electrochemistry for
battery etcetera he can pick up because
he has shown that ability to pick up a
new area
and and and
showing results
and i was talking to him and we were
again discussing this and he said
another thing that worked
on is they figured out that he had good
coding skills because when he was
writing his own codes on lattice
boltzmann method using matlab etc they
figured out that he knows coding and he
knows use of matlab these are also
transferable skills
so it's great that you brought this
point up so one of uh one of the
students actually asked this very
specific question that
he is doing his phd work writing his own
cfd codes
so
is there any possibility of such kind of
jobs in industry
i told you i told you an example right
away
and even when you are using standard
packages etcetera you most of the
complex problems you have to write your
own user defined functions right
okay so there are jobs and for example
to be asked if you ask me i cannot code
today okay
i that's that's my limitation that's my
incompetence i i could but i have not
most of the times i use packages as a
black box okay i define a geometry i put
boundary conditions i get results so can
whether the results are meaningful or
not maybe through experience i have
gathered some knowledge to figure out
what is what is good result what is what
is
junk
but what is this
but the software that that package the
tool like a fluent or an ice pack or a
flow thumb
or an ansys or an abacus these are the
black boxes for me to be honest
but
someone who has the capability to
actually write these codes etcetera is
extremely valuable and this is a
transferable scale to the earth okay so
these are some of the things so i i just
like to mention here because you
mentioned code
and i do like coding a little bit
not as much as one of these biscuits uh
in their third and fourth years but i do
like coding a little bit uh so nowadays
the buzzword is python so everyone and
in fact in that vbox report also it was
explicitly mentioned that in the very
immediate future python coding would be
something which would be given
importance by the industry
now usually when people think about
python nowadays these kids they
basically think of data science right
but much before i mean when when they
were kids
in school and didn't have to worry about
jobs or anything these these very same
kids back then when we were students so
i learned that uh python is like the
scripting language for a very important
software package called abacus which is
of extreme importance in solid mechanics
and even in other domains
overall in mechanical engineering
and the kind of scripting that you learn
in python can actually be
cross-purposed uh across a number of
different domains uh you have
open source packages uh
final element packages where the
scripting is done in piping so if a
person learns python there is an actual
a possibility of contributing in very
hardcore engineering uh applications
also absolutely absolutely
even even ai ml also you know uh you
know one part of aiml is what we hear
but uh even otherwise in in uh
in areas like diagnostics etc aiml is
becoming important
so uh
these are see these are tools these are
techniques these are skills you can
apply on various
areas in fact you brought out they
brought
you brought up data science
yeah data science data analytics can be
used for engineering problems
and
and can give some very meaningful
insights
okay and in fact if you have
a very core
knowledge in a technical domain
coupled with the knowledge in data
science that's a killer combination okay
because
because you can work in a core industry
and you bring in a skill set
which is absolutely unique which is
going to differentiate you
from the others okay
and maybe that is also something i want
to
people who work after working in the
industry for some time and after
reaching a certain level of seniority
you have to ask yourself that what is
my differentiating feature which makes
me valuable and unique to this company
okay every person is unique every person
is special
and you have to create your own identity
in your organization if this is the area
mr x is the person to go
a few years down the road not
immediately nobody expects you as a
fresh graduate to attain that
but maybe five seven ten years down the
road
that's what you should you would like to
attain
see progression in terms of
positions levels designations will
happen automatically
okay
but this is what you have to
work towards